[Müzik]
herkese Merhaba Hoş geldiniz bu güzel
günde Fethiye'de belki dışarıda olmak
Buradan daha mı İyidir bilmiyorum ama şu
ana kadar izlediğim konuşmacılarla
içeride olmayı tercih ettim Ağzınıza
sağlık Teşekkür ederim Kooperatifi
duyarak başlamak bana çok iyi geldi
özellikle sonra Görüntülüyü duyunca da
uçasım geldi yani bu yüksek tavana doğru
uçabilirim yani her an uçabilirim
gerçekten teşekkür ediyorum
Ben bir öğretmen olarak bugün biraz size
öğretmence değil de Öğretmen çocuğu gibi
konuşmak istiyorum aslında
Benimle ilgili yazarken aslında öğrenme
yolda dediler
bir öğretmen çocuğu olarak Hayata
gözlerimi bir okulun içinde açtım
gerçekten bir köy okulunun içerisinde
Babamın bir köy okulunda öğretmen
ve o gün bugündür 55 56 yaşına geldim
hala Okuldayım O yüzden de ben size
Bugün bir okul
gerçeği hakkında bir şeyler söylemek
istiyorum kendimden daha çok okula
anlatmak istiyorum okul dediğimiz şey
benim hayatımda şekillendirirken Hele
bizim kuşağa fazlaca şekillendirip şimdi
bu Konferansı yapan gençlerin hayatını
nasıl şekillendiriyor diye düşünüyorum
Çok havalı bir isim var Fen Lisesi
müthiş kaç tane fen lisesinden öğrenci
var bilmiyorum burada ama görüyorum
inanılmaz çocuklar o Çocukların hepsi Ee
birtakım sınavlara girerek buralarda
olmak için tırmaladılar
sadece kendilerine şunu sorsunlar onlar
gerçekten çok mu iyiydi geride
kalanlardan
ben soruyorum Geride kalanlar daha mı
kötüydü de onlar buradalar diğerleri
değil 1.7 milyon çocuk giriyor her yıl
Okulun evrildiği bir dünyada biz nereye
doğru gidiyoruz diye yarın da yaşamak
için bugünü iyi anlamak gerekir diye
söylüyorum belki bugüne bakmak lazım
35 yılı aşkın mesleki kariyerimde
dünyanın 55'ten fazla ülkesinde
Öğretmenlerle öğrencilerle anne
babalarla çalıştım içerik geliştirdim
okullarla çalıştım
otobüsü çalıştım
aslında bu okul dediğimiz kavramın
hepimiz biliyoruz ki modern zamanlardaki
okul dediğimiz kavram Aslında Bize
yaklaşık 200-300 yıllık tarihi
içerisindeki Sanayi toplumunun hediyesi
olan bir Kurumu taşıyoruz şu anda Yani
Sanayi toplumunu tüketmiş olan
insanlığın şu anda Sanayi topluluğundan
kalan fabrika yapılarının ihtiyacı olan
okul yapısını taşımaya çalışıp geleceği
insan yetiştirdiğini söylüyoruz
burada bir yalan var ya Birisi yalan
söylüyor gerçekten ya büyükler yalan
söylüyor ya Eğitimciler yalan söylüyor
ya Karar vericiler yalan söylüyor
bugünün okulları çocukları yarına
hazırlamıyor yalan aksine geçmişe
hazırlıyor
çok net söylüyorum Bir Eğitimci olarak
Çünkü birazdan buralarda burada gelip
konuşacak çok fazla şey konuşuyoruz
hayatın içinde o kadar çok kavram yer
değiştirdi ki evrildi ki gelin bakın
neler evriliyor bizim nelere bakmamız
gerekir onlara bir söyleyelim bakalım Ne
evliliği
bundan 25 yıl önce 30 yıl önce hatta 35
yıl önce benim
üniversiteye gireceğim yıllarda bize hep
şunlar söylenirdi Benim yaşım olanları
anlarlar senin Matematiğin iyi senin
fenini iyi Senin Türkçen iyi senin Sen
git şu mesleği seç Sen git bu mesleği
seç hepimize tarif edilmiş olan
meslekler vardır O yüzden de ne derlerdi
Bizim kızı ne doktorlar ne mühendisler
istedi başkasına vermezler diye kızları
Doktorlar mühendislere Dolayısıyla
hayatın kalbinde bir takım meslekler
vardı Ve bu mesleklere sahip olanlarda
hayatları boyunca o mesleğe ait
diplomayı alıp o diplomayla ömürlerini
bitiriyorlardı Bugünlerde çok
konuştuğumuz EYT gibi bize söylenen şey
neydi çalış 25 sene iyi bir işin olsun
sonra emekli ol Fethiye gibi bir yere
yerleş kıyıda bütün ömrünün karşılığını
alabilirsin diye söylenir diye şeyin
Oysa hayat değişti hayat nasıl değişti
Artık bir meslekte Hani bir çiçekle
bahar geçmez diye bir söz vardı ya
artık bir meslekle öbürü geçmiyor Hatta
bir meslek hiçbir işe yaramıyor Çünkü
bugün
teknolojinin gelişimi hızıyla hayatın
değişimi hızına baktığımız zaman şunu
görüyoruz ki özellikle teknik alanlarda
4 yılda bir üniversiteye giren birisinin
4 yılda 1 yılda aldığı bilginin alt
tehdit yani geçmiş bilgi olduğunu
eskimiş bilgi olduğunu görüyoruz
inanılmaz bir hızlıyız İnanılmaz bir
şeyle değişiyor Dolayısıyla artık okulun
görevi meslek edindirmekten hayatta
tutmaya doğru yürüyor yani pandemi
sırasında hepimizin gördüğü gibi iki
yumurta kırabilen birbirleriyle sohbet
edebilen Ee güntülü Az önce Harika bir
şey söyledi müthiş bir örnek vardı
konuşmanın içerisinde dedi ki;
TL olarak hesabında şu kadar vardı hem
de şu kadar dolar vardı Ben telefon edip
de bilet isteyebilirken istemedim ama
ben kendi ayaklarımın üstünde durmuş
işte onu nerede öğrendiyse Bravo ama
okul artık bunu öğretmeli
Çünkü biz
şuralardaki yetişkinlerin çoğu bunu
sokakta öğrendik koridorlarda öğrendik
arkadaşlarımızdan öğrendik bundan
yaklaşık eee
Fethiye'de olduğum için söyleyeyim
bundan yaklaşık
35-36 yıl önce şurada paspal turda
üniversite öğrencisiyken buradaki
barlarda çalışıyordum Ben yaz aylarında
iş bulamadığım sezonlar oluyordu iş
bulamadığım sezonlarda da mecburen
bulduğumuz yerlerde kalıyorduk hiçbirisi
cebinde geri dönecek param da olmuyordu
hiçbir zaman
Özellikle de öğrenci olduğum için
paramızı bitirip son kuruşumuzla tren
bileti alıp şeyle minibüslerle yukarıdan
denizden şey İstanbul'dan Denizli'ye
Denizli'den buraya geliyorduk bir daha
paramız kalmasın ki geri dönemeyelim
diye uğraşıyorduk paranızın kalmadığı
yerde yaratıcı olmayı öğrenebileceğiniz
yer Artık sokaklar değil okullar haline
gelmeli Okul evriliyor
bizim okuduğumuz yıllarda Dedim ya benim
babam köy öğretmeniydi
Babamlar gibi pek çoğu 17 yaşında
öğretmen oluyorlarmış yani Ortaokulu 13
yaşında köyünün kasabasında ortaokulunda
olan bu insanları bu öğretmen olur deyip
alıp yatılı öğretmen okullarına
gönderiyorlar 17 yaşında öğretmen olup
bir köye aydınlanmanın merkezi olarak o
kişileri gönderiyorlar Köyü aydınlatsın
Türkiye'ye aydınlatsın diye cumhuriyetin
kör öğretmenleri 17 yaşında Köyün en
bilgili olarak Çünkü zaten bir tek kitap
onlarda varmış okuma yazma bilen kişi
sayısı çok kitabın ve gazetenin
eriştiği kişiler onlarmış zamanla bu
görev değişiyor değişiyor değişiyor
kütüphaneleri daha çok kitaba daha çok
baskıya ama bugün geldiğimiz yerde şöyle
bir durum var artık bilginin erişimi ile
ilgili dünyada hiç kimsenin bir sorunu
kalmadı
en kötü okulda dahi İnternet erişiniz
varsa elinizdeki telefonla
dünyanın en büyük dijital
kütüphanelerine ulaşarak en eski veriler
dahil olmak üzere güçlü
karşılaştırılabilir doğrulanabilir
veriye erişme şansınız var Burada sadece
neye ihtiyacımız var veri
okuryazarlığına bilgi okuryazarlığına
ihtiyacımız var Çünkü artık bilgi veriye
ulaşmanın hiçbir sınırı yok hatta bedava
Hatta ücretsiz istediğiniz saatte
istediğiniz dakikada ulaşabiliyorsunuz
peki burada karşımıza çıkan şey ne
bilgiye ulaşmak bir şey olmadığına göre
bizim o bilgiye ulaşmaktan ya da o
bilgiye maruz kalmaktan ötürü açığa
çıkacak olan
beceriyle donanmış olmaya ihtiyacımız
var bizim kuşaklarda popüler de ee
80'lerin sonu 90'ların başı üniversiteyi
bitirdiğimiz zaman herkesin en büyük
hevesi şeydi bankanın fetişliği sınavına
girmek çok popülerdi bütün bizde frenler
bir banka müfetti sınavına girer bu
oyunda ölçüsünü alırdı iki sınav vardı
bir tanesi matematik sınavı bir tanesi
genel kültür sınavı genel kültür zaten
üniversiteye girerken de sorulurdu orada
aynı şekilde matematik sınavı da
neredeyse aynı limit matematik türev
bunları falan sorarlardı yani orada
Dolayısıyla sizin lisede ve üniversitede
bilgi olarak karşılaştığınız şeyi başka
bir iş sahibi olabilmek için aynı şeyi
soruyorlardı yani burada öğrendiğini
burada kullanıyordun şimdi bu dünyada
böyle bir şey yok Bak burada bir şey
öğreniyorsun ama burada Onu sormuyorlar
sana burada diyorlar ki böyle böyle bir
örnek olay gelirse sen ne yaparsın diyor
mesela ben soruyorum gençlere çok daha
sıklıkla soruyorum Bizim lise
mezunlarına şunu soruyorum diyorum ki
gençler
1 milyon dolarım var ve Sivas'ta
yaşıyorum 1 milyon dolarla Sivas'ta 5
yıllığına Bir yatırım yapmak istiyorum
Zarar etmek istemiyorum 5 yıl sonra En
kötü ihtimalle paramı alıp çıkıp eksik
yapabileyim çıkış yapabileyim Biz de
genellikle cevaplar şu şekilde başlıyor
ne kadar süremiz var hatta süreyi bize
sormuyor sonra ellerindeki telefonlara
genç arkadaşlar hemen yazıyor Sivas'ta 1
milyon dolara ne iş yapılır
Halbuki bilgiyi beceriye dönüştürmüş
olan okullardan mezun olanları size
şöyle soruyorlar
Sivas'ın kıt olan kaynakları nelerdir
Örneğin
Sivas'ta en çok bulunan hammadde
nelerdir Sivas'ın ekonomik yapısından
nelere ihtiyaç vardır gibi
eleştirel aklı zorlayan bir şey
oluşturacak olan bir şey soruyor
Dolayısıyla
okulun ham bilgiyi veriyor olması
sanıyorum bu bilgiyi veriyor olmasından
geçip artık okulun beceriye dönüştürmesi
gerekiyor Peki bu sorunun cevabı da şu
Aslında biraz da şunu sormakta fayda var
okulların beceri merkezi olması için ne
yapmak lazım
okulların beceri Merkezi olabilmesi için
önce beceriyi nasıl ölçeceğimizin
farkına varmak lazım
mesela Siz hiç burada ebeveyn olanlara
soruyorum ya da öğrenci arkadaşlarıma
soruyorum sizin matematik sınavlarınızın
sonunda ben bir matematik öğretmeniyim
mesleğe matematik öğretmeni olarak
başladım
hani matematik ne işe yarar sorusunun
cevabı sevgili Ali'nin söylediği gibi
Hadi matematik hayatınıza direkt etki
etmez ama en direk olarak hayatınızın en
önemli parçasıdır der Ali Nesin şöyle
bir şey söyleyeceğim size matematik ne
işe yarar sorularını hocalarınız genelde
şunu söylerler işte risk almanızı sağlar
Analitik düşünmenizi sağlar Bütün
bunların altına matematikte var değil mi
bütün matematik hocaları Benzer şeyleri
peki sizce karnenizde matematik ile
ilgili risk alma notunuzun kaç olduğunu
gördünüz mü
hiç insiyatifimizin kaç olduğunu
gördünüz mü yoksa kaç tane soru
çözebildiğinizin notunu görüyorsunuz
orada ya ben Trek çözebiliyorum da
trileçe çözmemin gerçekten Risk almaya
ne kadar faydası olduğunu bana ölçen
biri var mı
mesela fizikte trenin arasındaki
ilişkinin güncel hayatta hani birinin
hızla öbürünün değeri ivme ile ilgisi
var neyse matematik fiziğe geçiyorum
okul bir şeye dönüşmesi lazım Yeni ehli
yerlerden bir tanesi de bu çok önemli
pardon
gitti mi
şimdi bugünlerde
okulla ilgili en çok söylenen şeylerden
bir tanesi bu genellikle anne babalar Az
önce sunucu genç arkadaşım da dedik ya
işte yem okullarını kurucusu laboratuvar
türlerinde bir okul grubumuz var bizimde
bütün bu programları orada
geliştiriyoruz beceri odaklı programları
okulun dönüşünü falan
özellikle genç anne babalar anaokuluna
çocuk yazdırmak için geliyorlar ve şöyle
diyorlar hocam sizin okulun LGS başarısı
neydi
anaokuluna yazdırıyor 8 sene basit
hesapla ilkokul ortaokul var hani bir de
3 yaşa falan yazdırıyorsa 11 sene sonra
şöyle basit bir şey söylüyorum bakın
hepiniz seslerin Lütfen kendinizi
düşünün kendinizi şöyle bir sayı doğrusu
gibi düşünün bugün Bulunduğunuz anı 0
noktası olarak kabul edin bugünden
geriye doğru 8 yıl geriye gidin bugünden
geleceğe de 8 yıldır sadece Şimdi iki
tane periyot var burada geçmişteki
bugünden geçmişe yani 2023 dersek 8 yıl
geriye gidersek 2015
2015'te 2023'ün aralığında hayatınızda
olanları düşünün
hayatın hızının hiç değil değişmediğini
düşünürseniz
2023'te 2008 yıl daha 2031 arasında ne
olacağını bir farz edin Bakalım
korkarsınız
neler olduğunu 2015'te 2020 içerisinde
bir göktaşı düşmedi
sayayım isterseniz yani enflasyonlar
devalüasyonlar o seçim Bu seçim siyaset
değişimi deprem daha sayayım mı size
yani şey pandemi bu 8 yılın hiç
değişmeden aynı 8 Yılını daha Aynı hızda
yaşayacağım deseniz Hocam biz
yaşamayalım Bu kadar yeterli
okul böyle olacaksa Sen nasıl kalkıp da
şimdiden daha ne olduğu belli olmayan
LGS sınavının başarısını soruyorsun
hocam sevgili anne baba
çocuklara soruyoruz
çocuklara sorduğumuz zaman çocukların
hiçbirisi karneyi umursamıyor bakın
burada genç bir sürü arkadaşım var karne
Oyunmuş karne buymuş mutluymuş
hiçbirisinde umurunda değil okul Çünkü
artık tamamıyla
sosyal başarı sağladığımız yeni bir alan
Yeni Bir Dünya haline geldi çünkü
çocuklar daha çok bu tip konferansları
yapmalı çocuklar daha çok buralarda
sahip olabilmeli çocuklar daha çok
buralarda girişimci olmalılar çocuk daha
çok buralarda söz sahibi olmaya
ihtiyaçları var otonomiye ihtiyaçları
var üretmeye ihtiyaçları var az önce
Berk burada geldi dedi ki; ben dedi
kendi işimi Öğretmek istiyordum Oysa
bizim okuduğumuz Okullar ne yapıyor
kağıt kalem artencraft bol bol proje
yapıyoruz süper sene sonuna bakın
okullar Kağıt yapıyor her tarafta Kağıt
süper projeler var kağıt üstünde herkes
seni aynı projeler bir daha yapılıyor
Gene kağıt aynı projeler bir daha
yapılıyor patent yok çocuğun gelişimi
yok bizim okuduğumuz yıllarda kooperatif
En azından okulun en güzel en güzel
sosyal girişimiydi sosyal girişim
dediğin zaman aklınıza gelen şey
kooperatif o kolunun içinde çocuğun
işlettiği hiçbir şey yok
çocuğun yönettiği hiçbir yemeğine karar
vermiyor saatine karar veremiyor geliş
gidişine karar veririm ya Hatta daha
ötesinde bir şey söyleyeyim seçmeli
dersine karar veremiyor
basit bir örnek vereyim size bu ara
gençlerle ilgili bir araştırma veri
topluyorum gençlere sordum yaklaşık
5.000 veri top 5.000 öğrenciden beri
aldık şu anda liseliler Fethiye Belediye
fen lisesine de göndereceğim araştırmayı
belki herhalde herkesten veri
gençlere sorduk
Eğer elinizde olsaydı aşağıdaki
derslerden hangisini lise bir süratini
eklerdiniz diye birinci sırada demokrasi
ve insan hakları dersi geldi
birinci sırada biz şey bekliyorduk iklim
krizi falan gelir diye bekliyorduk şu
anda görünen o demokrasi ve niye geldi
aslında biliyor musunuz çocuklar
güncelde yaşıyorlar zaten onu görüyorlar
Peki bunu isterlerken biliyor musunuz ki
lisenin müfredatında böyle bir ders var
çocuklarına veriyor böyle bir derse
böyle bir ders seçmeli ders olarak var
sevgili okul yöneticisi arkadaşlarım bu
dersi seçmeli ders olarak çocuklara
zorla veriyorlar sonra hocası olarak
matematik öğretmen atıyorlar matematik
öğretmenleri daha çok matematik testi
çözerek çocukların daha demokratik ve
insan haklarını bilir çocuklar olmasını
sağlıyorlar Süper değil mi Harika
matematik soruları çözen çocuklar
demokrasi ve insan hakları olunca
sınıfta kalıyorlar
gençlerin en çok şikayet ettiği
şeylerden bir tanesi bu yaklaşık
özellikle salgın öncesinde de 10 tane
kadar liseli gençlerin WhatsApp
gruplarının içerisindeyim onları
izliyorum Ee sessiz katılımcı olarak
onlardan Ee öğrenmeye çalışıyorum
gençlerden en çok öğrendiğim şeylerden
bir tanesi bu gençler şunu diyorlar ya
bıktık artık
habire geleceği bize emanet ediyorsunuz
içini batırıp batırıp bize emanet
ediyorsun batırıp batırıp geleceği Siz
kurtaracağız bırakın bugünü kurtaralım
bari biliyorsunuz geleceği siz
kurtaracaksanız siz niye böyle
davranıyorsunuz Bakın bu zevk kuşağı
gençlerin çok net söylediğim şey niye
sürekli bizi geleceği havale ediyorsunuz
Biz buradayız varız şu anda Niye bizi
kullanmıyorsunuz geçmişte benim babam 17
yaşında öğretmenken Biz şu fen liseli
çocukları niye kullanmıyorsunuz
niye Bu çocuklardan bir şey üretmelerini
istemiyoruz daha bile geleceğe atıfta
bulunuyoruz çocuklarda bunu diyor bizi
kullanın
bizi duyun bizi dinleyin bizi böyle
kağıt kalem işleriyle zaman harcatmayın
Çünkü bir daha daha var bu konuşmada
kaydı gelsin diye söyleyeceğim sonuna
doğru geliyorum süre azalıyor sosyal
deney olarak söylüyorum Bugünlerde çok
fazla yerde söylüyorum söylemeye devam
edeceğim Türkiye Cumhuriyeti'nde şu anda
ülkemizde
8 sınıfı bitiren çocukları doğrudan
üniversiteye koysak yani 4 yıllık liseyi
aradan çıkarsa hiçbir değişim olmaz
Çünkü üniversitede hocalık yapıyorum
bana gelen Çocuklar orada hala iki satır
paragraf yazamıyorlar Neden sonuç
ilişkisi kuramıyorlar Basit mi Şu
problemi çözerek gelemiyor çocuk oraya
üniversiteye geldiği zaman cebimde 1000
liram vardı bakkala gittim kilosu 250
lira olan peynirden 150 gram aldım işte
tanesi 5 lira olan yumurtadan 22 tane
aldım kalan paramın üçte birini de
buraya verdim cebimde kaç para kaldı bak
paraya hiç gerek yok değil mi Şu salonun
hepsi Normalde bu kadar uzun olması da
bunu herkes ortalama matematik dediğim
şey matematik matematik çözemiyorlar
O zaman niye lise okuyorlar boşuna
okuyorlar lisenin %90'ı bu durumda o
yüzden kapatın gitsin başka bir şey
yapalım
ve bu çocukların hepsinin en önemli şeyi
şu not kaygısı kalmadı çünkü Zaten
herkes 100 alıyor
fark etmiyor Mesela bir arkadaşım
Geçenlerde akademisyen Bizim ekipten bir
arkadaş Türker sevgili Türker falan
kulaklarının
girmeden önceki son gün karneleri
verildiği gün tweet attık dedi ki Ee
korkuyorum dedim Milli Eğitim
Bakanlığına soracağım verilen teşekkürü
ve taktır sayısını ama öğrenci sayısını
geçeceğini düşündüğüm için soramıyorum
dedi
teşekkür takdir almayan var mı
etrafınızda arkadaş ya Bir Baksanıza
Etrafınıza yani önüne gelen teşekkür
takdirle geçiyor nereye duracağız artık
yani bu kadar yukarıya O yüzden de
çocuklarını hiç birisinin not filan
umurlarında değil Çünkü bu çocuklar bu
notların kendilerini anlatmadığını
biliyorlar artık onların bir tek gerçek
kaygısı var notu geçeceğim diyor Ben
diyor bunu yapabiliyor muyum bakın bugün
sahnedeki çocukların Sabahtan beri
heyecanlarını görüyorum canavar gibiler
hepsi dört gözle bakıyorlar hepsi
soruyor hocam olmuş mu abi olmuş mu abi
ne diyorsun Bu çocukların Usta Çırak
ilişkisiyle yapmaya öğrenmeye ve
büyümeye ihtiyaçları var Bu çocukların
habire anlamsız notlar almaya
ihtiyaçları yok artık ve çok kritik
olduğunu düşündüğüm bir şey okul artık
herhangi bir bilgiye hamallık ederek
ezberleyen değil ezber bozan yeni bir
alışkanlığa vermek zorunda hani eski
köye yeni adetler çıkarmak zorunda olan
isyan eden hayır diyen 21 yüzyılın Okulu
dediğiniz Okulu ya da sınıfları çok
kolay anlayabilirsiniz bir sınıf niye
okula girin koridora bakın koridorda zil
çaldığı anda sınıflardan öğrencilerin
çıkışını İzleyin eğer sınıflardan hurra
diye gelenekseldir ya bu Zil çalar
koşarak çocuklar çıkar ama Bir sınıf var
çıkmadı hala ne oluyor falan diyorsunuz
Kapı açılıyor öğretmen çıkıyor
öğretmenlerin etrafında da bir sürü
öğrenci itiraz ediyorlar Hayır hocam ama
böyle işte gerçek sınıf odur
işte İhtiyacınız olan odur O Okulu
yaratabiliyorsanız ezber bozan çocuklar
yaparsınız özetle sona Gelecek olursak
dünyanın bu kadar hızla değiştiği bir
dünyada daha biz
Okulu aynı tutabilir miyiz şimdi benden
sonra çıkacak bir sürü konuşmacı da buna
benzer şeyler söyleyecekler benim Sorum
şu Bir Eğitimci eğitim bilimci olarak
akademisyen olarak benim Sorum şu biz bu
çocuklara haksızlık tutmuyor muyuz bu
okulu neden hala Sanayi Devriminin
okuluyla LGS Sınavı ile ÖSS sınavıyla
tarif etmeye çalışıyoruz sevgili gençler
sevgili büyükler herkes fikirdi ama ben
de son cümleyle söyleyeyim
yılda yaklaşık 850 bin kişi Türkiye'de
üniversite sınav sonucu yerleştiriliyor
ÖSYM tarafından üniversite yerleştirilen
kişi sayısı 850.000 bu kontenjanımız
bizim yıllar önce 50 bin 100 bin filandı
şimdi her yıl 859.000 kişiyi
yerleştiriyoruz 2,5 milyon kişinin
girdiği bir sınav sonucunda
850.000 kişinin bu sene yerleşmiş
850.000 kişinin içinden kaç tanesinin
uluslararası alanda rekabet edebilir bir
mesleği Garanti
15-20 tane çıkaramazsınız o halde
derdimiz artık bu değil derdimiz daha
iyi bir okula ve hatta hemen öğütler
dünyasına giderken bakın hepinizin
kolunda giyilebilir saatler giyilebilir
teknolojiler var artık insandan hemen
aletlere doğru geçiyoruz Bu yüzyılda 150
yıl yaşayan yüzyılın sonunda yarı insan
yarı makinalara Doğru gideceğiz bizim
burada oluşturduğumuz şey yeni bir okula
ihtiyacı var onunla da insan okul bir
insan Okulu oluşturmak dileğiyle
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]